hey guys guess what i'm gonna go out
this window but before i do that watch
how hard it was for me to get here
come on baby just a little bit just do
it for me
come on baby you know you want to god
damn it come on
hard can this be ah come on i can't even
get up the chair anymore
am i doing something wrong i'm gonna
kill you with a rusty spork
stabbed in your eyeball and shove it out
your butt if you don't let me up there
mortally i'm not even speaking english
anymore it's floyd
oh there we go isn't that something okay
we're going through the window now
as you know they're only oh
i heard something at first stanley
assumed he'd broken the map
until he heard this narration and
realized it was part of the game's
design all along
he then praised the game for its
insightful and witty commentary
into the nature of video game structure
and its examination of structural
narrative tropes
so now that you're here what do you
think isn't this a fun and unique place
to be
it's white we take a minute just to
drink it all in
okay i'm over it now what do you think
are you sick of this gag yet
uh no ah
then in that case we'll continue but now
here comes the real question
okay what do you think would have
happened if you had told me that you
wanted this to stop
do you think it would have been
particularly different would i have
taken the same idea but rephrased it
superficially to fit that answer
perhaps you never would even have
thought of it if i hadn't brought up the
issue in the first place
oh now think about it would it be worth
it for you to restart and then come back
here
just to do the other option clearly this
whole gag takes some time
what if the other option is even longer
how long will you spend in total just to
have heard
all the narration oh and this is rich
perhaps you've just played the other
option
and now you've come to see what happens
in this one oh so
what do you think which choice was the
better one my brain hurts
and if you had selected continue on your
first playthrough
how tantalizing it would be not knowing
what happens
when you pick the other option indeed
you are one of the lucky ones
though if the other option is really
miserable to listen to
then perhaps you're not in fact i'm just
going to say that no one who's listening
to this
is lucky well now i've built up the
other options
so much that i'm going to stop talking
and leave you to your decision
whether to come back here continue with
the game or just sit in this spot
forever
and ever cheers wow thanks man
you're such a good friend to me i can't
wait to do this again
i'm not gonna do it again
yeah i'm stuck in the perpetual abyss of
nothingness
let's begin again i'm not gonna go out
that window again because it was hard
enough in the first place to try to even
get to it
now the other ending that they have here
is the cheating one
oh what is this hobby uh oh
uh oh stanley this is me being serious
huh
in fact this is my serious room oh it's
where i come to be serious
really that table is the most serious
table i could find
i looked at many many tables hundreds of
tables
it's possible i looked at over a
thousand tables i honestly don't know
the specific number isn't as important
as the understanding that of
all tables i looked at this one is the
most serious
i relate this story to impress upon you
the extent to which this is the most
serious room i have
which is why i brought you here you just
tried to activate
server cheats which of course runs the
risk
of breaking the entire game you've got
no respect
for the strict order of scripted
narrative events
and i just can't have that i wouldn't
know it's time to get serious stanley
no jokes no games outside of this room
i might be more tolerant of those things
but now we're in the room
which is why i'm subjecting you to the
most serious punishment i can think of
okay 100 billion trillion years
standing here in the serious room
perhaps after that
we can talk about the severity of your
actions and whether you've learned
anything
oh but until then serious room
go
that's pretty funny man that's pretty
funny now let me out
let me out let me out okay i'm gonna
okay that was another ending that was
the serious ending
i would laugh if i started oh i would
laugh if i started the game again
and then suddenly i was back in the
serious room and the game
never went back to normal again okay so
there's one more ending and this is one
thing
am i sure that the orders stopped coming
in
how is that possible no i've checked
that before stopped surely i was
mistaken
no shut up narrator i've always i've
already checked
now i know what i need to do for this
next one because a lot of you guys have
been suggesting it for me
he came to a set of two open doors he
entered the door on his left
a door on his left and then i go into
the meeting room
where i could stand here and watch the
whiteboard ending
i don't i don't know which one is the
whiteboard ending but stanley decided to
go
up to his boss's office yeah hoping he
might find an answer there
i don't want to stand around for the
whiteboard ending because
frankly it's quite boring coming to a
staircase stanley walked upstairs to his
boss's office
yes and this is where things get a
little tricky okay
what i need to do is i need to walk
through these doors
but then walk back before they close on
me okay
so let's see
yeah i did it do i get to go in the
executive bath what
wait a minute if i get to go in no
oh well
i guess i gotta go back downstairs
yes all right what's gonna happen
wait a minute what wait what
well that's that's closed now okay so i
got to go back the way i came i guess
the narrator is awfully silent
hello did i
he doesn't even care that i went in the
broom closet something must be seriously
up with him
oh this is slightly disconcerting
okay
hello i actually don't actually
i haven't seen like how this ends like
that's i haven't spoiled it for myself
all i knew
was how to get to it so i'm awfully
confused am i going all the way back to
my own office
oh who will
what's all this then
oh i can't move oh there we go you are
now
leaving oh that's good is that for real
that's a red door escape car
escape pod bay and then 274.
wait a minute is that the other side of
the office hey all the lights went out
in the office
that's weird and that's the desk i
climbed over just to get to this ending
floor 760. whoa
hot damn okay i can barely see but
that's all right
7 55. wait a minute it's the same thing
it's the same thing
it's the exact same thing but the all
the floors are wait a minute
756 and it's the same thing in there
how many stanley's are there that's
actually a good question because
there's no saying that the narrator
doesn't have multiple versions of the uh
participant playing through it and it's
kind of proven that
stanley has been looping this life over
and over again that's been pretty well
established in all the other ones
that i've played before it's the same
thing over and over again
i mean this game is perpetually designed
to mess with your mind and it's getting
darker every time i go in those
staircases
one more uno mas and then i make it to
the escape pod
now let's pitch black
hello escape pod launch bay
why don't there need to be an escape pod
escape
it was escaped before but i didn't trust
it
where am i go
where oh there we are well hello there
what are you is this for real
whoa what the what happened
what everything went white on the what
now it's loading ah what
what happened i didn't even know what
happened
are you joking me that was it
a soft wind blew outside and perhaps
rain started
and if it did it stopped shortly after
stanley hoped that he would one day see
weather what does that mean that's
totally different
i'm so confused i'm so confused
i'm so utterly confused
did something actually change or what
danny came to a set of two open doors
he entered the door on his left ah god
okay
i guess that was it i don't know if
something spectacular was supposed to
happen or not but
my game might have bugged out i don't
know okay
well that was the spectacular escape bad
ending let me try to find another
hang on
all right there's another another ending
that you guys wanted me to do
to the meeting room understand he knew
it perfectly
perhaps he wanted to stop by the
employee lounge first just to admire it
perhaps i have admired it in the past
yes truly a room worth admired but yeah
to get back to business stanley took the
first open door on his left how about no
thank you very much i have a purpose
stanley was so bad at following
directions it's incredible he wasn't
fired years ago
sorry sorry to disappoint senor i think
perhaps we've gotten off on the wrong
foot here i'm not your enemy really i'm
not
yeah i realize that investing your trust
in someone else can be difficult
but the fact is that the story has been
about nothing but you
all this time huh there's someone you've
been neglecting stanley
yeah someone you've forgotten about
please
stop trying to make every decision by
yourself now i'm not asking for me
i'm asking for help
really stanley your chance to redeem
yourself
to put your work aside to let her back
into your life
she's been waiting really she has
oh my you need to be the one to do this
i do reach out to her reach out to this
plugin
place your face in another then pick up
the phone
about no as stanley picked up the phone
a white light engulfed him
filling him not just with radiance but
with hope hope for a life reunited one
wait oh goodness stanley did you just
unplug the phone yes no that wasn't
supposed to be a choice how did you do
that
i you actually chose incorrectly
yeah i didn't even know that was
possible let me double check
no it's definitely here clear as day
stanley
picks up the phone he's taken to his
apartment where he finds his wife
and the two pledge themselves to one
another music comes in
fake to white real credits that's not
what happened picking up the phone
is actually somehow an incorrect course
of action how is that even possible
none of these decisions were supposed to
mean anything i don't understand
how on earth are you making meaningful
choices what did you
wait a second did i just see no
that's not possible i can't believe it
had i not noticed it sooner
you're not stanley you're a real person
oh
i can't believe i was so mistaken this
is why you've been able to make correct
and incorrect choices and to think i've
been letting you run around in this game
for so long
if you've made any more wrong choices
you might have negated it entirely
it's as though you completely ignored
even the most basic
safety protocol for real-world
decision-making or did you not
grasp the severity of the situation well
i won't have that kind of risk on my
watch
i'm going to stop the game for a moment
so we can educate you properly on safe
decision making in the real world
okay please observe this helpful
instructional video
oh choice it's the best part of being a
real person
but if used incorrectly can also be the
most dangerous
for example in this scenario a
hypothetical real person named steven
has a choice
he could spend years helping improve the
quality of life for citizens
of impoverished third world nations or
he could systematically set fire to
every orphan
living in a 30 kilometer radius of his
house which
choice would you make remember that
unlike here the real world makes sense
and at no time should you make a choice
that does not conform to rational logic
if you find yourself speaking with a
person who does not make sense
in all likelihood that person is not
real
allow the person to finish their thought
then provide an excuse why you cannot
continue
talking turn to a partner and practice
saying
my goodness is it 4 30 i'm supposed to
be having
a back sack and crack
a what my goodness is it 4
30 i'm supposed to be having a back sack
and crack
whatever that is i know that i want it
making choices on a regular basis is the
best part to a healthy decision-making
process
most medical professionals recommend
making at least eight choices per day
do you make more than eight less and
finally
if you begin to wonder if your choices
are actually meaningful and whether
you'll ever make a significant
contribution to the world
just remember that in the vast
infiniteness of space
your thoughts and problems are
materially insignificant
and the feeling should subside at this
time
your instructor will guide you in an
exercise to test and reinforce the
material covered in this video
whoa welcome back you may have noticed
that this room has begun to deteriorate
as a result of narrative contradiction
oh but not to worry
now that you're probably informed on
good decision making we're going to
revisit a choice you made just a few
minutes ago
okay what the correct thing to do would
have been this way please
all right but
did that remind anyone of like fallout 3
ish
just a little bit ah whatever just the
way that movie was set up
so what am i doing now
now that we know your choices are
meaningful we can't have you jumping off
the platform and dying
mention the main character dying
senselessly halfway through the story
that story would make no sense at all
okay we just need to get you home as
soon as possible
before the narrative contradiction gets
any worse okay
fortunately it seems this place is not
well equipped to deal with reality
oh isn't that a bit of a problem
shouldn't every place be equipped to
deal with reality
isn't that your job oh okay
guy finally realized i'm not standing in
everything stanley and everything's
going to crap
okay so what choice am i exactly
revisiting guy
mysterious voice in my head and the sky
okay you'll take the door on the left
back to the correct ending the story
will have resolution once again
and you'll be home free in the real
world
will i i'm not sure because even those
endings over there which i've already
visited and you know i did
seem to have caused problems now
remember all you need to do is behave
exactly as stanley would
that means choosing responsibly and
always putting the story first
okay i'm quite sure you'll be up to the
task just follow my lead and you'll be
fine
okay all right when stanley came to a
set of two open doors
he entered the door on his left
okay let me put myself in stanley modern
okay that's dumb i'm going on the right
no oh you do that quickly hurry back in
the other direction perhaps we're not
too late
oh no oh no
everything seems to be gone horribly
wrong whoa
whoa holy crap okay i'm sorry
i apologize sincerely let me go back
anything no okay all right i'll go
i'll play your game you rogue
anything things look normal so far how
about the whiteboard room
ah it's rained i can't believe after
everything we talked about that you
my story you've destroyed my work
why for what what did you get out of
that
what did you think was so special about
seeing the game undone
left here like so much garbage it's
worthless now what am i supposed to do
even if there were a way to continue
would it be worth it to know that my
story is now incorrect how can i go back
to that
i can't erase that knowledge i'll have
to live with it forever
reliving its impossibility forever i
couldn't live that way
is it better to shut the game down
entirely to willingly destroy all of my
work
i don't know what's the answer what do i
do
what do i do not to like no i have to
i have to shut the game down no i
have to now this is the most interesting
part
ah don't shut it down oh god
damn it it was just getting cool
oh wait a minute whoa
what the hell
i'm here i'm still here here in this
pile of rubbish
with you yes you who thought you were so
clever
now look where we are my entire game is
destroyed
it was the only thing in the world that
was mine and you run it into the ground
what did you think that would be funny
you just had to see
didn't i impress upon you how important
it was to be like stanley
he actually knows how to do what i tell
him to he understands that if i say to
do something there's a damn good reason
for it
that thought hadn't even occurred to you
had it that there's a world outside of
you
you're a child oh
my story if you'd just gone through the
door on the left you would have seen it
there was a whole
underground facility you would have
destroyed it and been victorious
it would have been so perfect i worked
so hard on it
i tried so hard oh
this behave exactly as stanley wood what
that means choosing responsibly
and always putting the story first i'm
quite sure you'll be up to the task
just follow my lead and you'll be fine
all right
when stanley came to a set of two open
doors
he entered the door on his left wait a
minute
something has gone terribly wrong
what's going on no why did you do that
quickly hurry up piss
when stanley came to a set of two open
doors
he entered the door on his left stanley
modern gate
left that's a good choice
i love your left doing whatever the
narrator wants me to person here either
healing wave of disbelief he decided to
go up to his boss's office
i think he might find an answer there
good now i can't get into broom closet
cause i wouldn't do that if stanley
wouldn't do it
come on in case stanley walked upstairs
to his boss's office oh
yeah giggles out there so i'll go
upstairs
something's going horribly wrong wait a
minute
it's different that's totally different
what would happen if i i'm curious
in his manager's office stanley was once
again stunned to discover
not an indication of any human life ah
shocked
unraveled stanley wandered in disbelief
who orchestrated this
until he saw the door with a voice
receiver next to it
surely behind this door lay all the
answers to his questions
okay and beyond all probability he knew
the passcode
he had seen it on his boss's computer
just last week
night shark 115. was this the code to
open the door
would it still work there was only one
way to find out
stanley had been trained never to speak
up but now
he would draw from within himself the
courage to face
the unknown he drew a sharp breath
and then spoke the code night shock
115.
no no
no wait what stanley's where's that guy
killing a panda
knight shark one one five let's check
one one five yeah
into the receiver yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay i got it i gotta go i gotta get it
again
ah night shock one one five
problem you didn't mishear me did you
please speak the code into the receiver
otherwise we can't get on with the story
this is a crucial
step i'm practically screaming it man
stanley can't do this let me get hey
fine you're not gonna do it
but you know what it's pretty
humiliating to bring you this far only
for you to suddenly decide you have
better things to do
i asked you for this one single thing
for your respect
the kind of respect stanley shows for
his choices
he knows what it means to take a story
seriously
if you didn't want to see what i had to
show you then why did you come here
you had a choice you know you could have
gone through the door on the right you
could have done whatever the hell you
wanted over there
why did you come this way speak say
something to me
explain yourself you coward
when he came to a set of two open doors
he entered the door on his
are left is everything okay
stanley please i i need you to make a
choice
i need you to walk through the door are
you listening to me
can you hear me is everything all right
stanley this is important the story
needs you it needs you to make a
decision
it cannot exist without you do you
understand me whatever choice you make
is just fine they're both correct you
can't be wrong here we can work together
i'll accept whatever you do i simply
need you to take that step forward
please
choose do something
anything this is more important than you
can ever know
i need this the story needs it
so you hear me are you there
you're listening to this danny are you
there
okay it's okay i can wait
you need time to decide time to make
sure your choice is correct that is the
best
choice that's all right
i'll wait for you to decide what's the
right thing to do
take as much time as you need
oh my heart hurts
oh was that the official official end
ah that was so sad
oh that was so sad but somehow
satisfying
really emphasizes the choice this game
is all about
choice and when you remove choice there
is no game
ah it was beautiful ah it was beautiful
there's also one more ending that i want
to do real quick but ah but stanley
simply couldn't handle the
beautiful what if he had to make a
decision what if a crucial outcome fell
under his responsibility
he had never been trained for that oh no
this couldn't go any way except badly
yeah the thing to do now stanley thought
to himself is to wait
is there something will hurt me exactly
nothing will break me
yes in here i can be happy forever
yes i will be happy yes stanley waited
hours passed then days had years gone by
he no longer had the ability to tell but
the one thing he knew for sure
beyond any doubt was that if he waited
long enough the answers would come
eventually someday they would arrive
soon very soon now this will end
he will be spoken to he will be told
what to do
now it's just a little bit closer
now it's even closer here it comes
yeah that was the uh that was one of the
last endings i don't know if there are
any other endings that i missed but i'm
just gonna count this as
my final episode because when i saw that
last ending the one with the actual
official credits and all
oh that was amazing that was so cool
oh so cool oh man this game is fantastic
i mean it must have taken
so long to like plan everything out come
up with all the endings get the
narrative record
all those lines god this was a great
game i'm gonna have a
i'm gonna call this one i got like a lot
of endings i don't think i
don't think i missed any i may have
missed some let me know if i did
uh maybe i'll revisit it like a live
stream or something but
that's it for the stanley parable hope
you guys enjoyed it it was absolutely
phenomenal i'd love this game to death
so
thank you all so much for watching click
the end of days for more videos that
i've done
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
i shall dispose of the remaining
material to myself she looks kind of
creepy
come mario doctor
shut up
she's aware of our relationship
make sure